Get your bucket of water balloons ready, because
we're gonna need them. In this project
we're converting our rocket rifle into a high
power water balloon launcher.
For this project, I stopped by the dollar
store and picked up a pack of 100 water balloons
for a buck. These are the small ones, and
we only need to fill them up to about a 2"
diameter. We'll also need to use these pre-made
cannon wads that we formed in the "Candy Cannon"
project. These wads are made out of cheap plastic cups prevent the water balloons from bursting during the
launch. If you don't have plastic cups, I
found that 2" water balls can work pretty
well as a substitute. Ok, to make a water
balloon cannon let's grab our rocket launcher,
and unscrew the barrel, because this will
act as our ramrod. With the rocket barrel
removed, it's time to attach the "cannon adaptor".
This is made with a 2' length of 2" PVC pipe,
and some reducer fittings. The plastic wad
goes in, and gets pushed all the way to the
bottom, then we can add a little water, or
vegetable oil, for lubrication just prior
to inserting a purple water balloon. Alright,
it's ready for a test, so I'll hook up my
air hose, and set the compressor to 65 PSI.
Holding the launcher at about a 45 degree
angle, let's get ready to fire. You'll probably
notice the plastic wads falling away to the
side, and the balloon is really out there.
So far, in-fact, that nobody can keep it in
sight. It easily clears the white fence over
300 feet away. Well I'm pretty happy about
that, so let's see what else it can do. One of my little boys is gonna try out 3 balloons
at once, and with the help of a friend, it's
a great shot. Let's try this out with the
Candy Cannon! It's already got a 2" barrel
so no modifications are necessary. Just lock,
and load. The air hose is attached, and the
valve opened so it's ready to go. All it takes
now is a press of the detonator button, and
we've got a gorgeous array of liquid projectiles!
If you're loading a balloon that's a little
too big, just give the barrel a little shake,
and it should slide on down. If you want to
go portable, just close the manual valve and
disconnect the air hose. Your system is still
charged and ready to fire. These balloon blasters
are intense. If you want a real challenge,
try shooting the balloons straight up and
catching them on the way back down. This is working great, so let's go bigger.
I've just loaded 13 water balloons to see what happens. Aaah, that was a little weak. Let's bump the pressure
up to about 90 PSI and see if that makes a
difference. Yeah, that's working much better.
So for multiple balloons we just need higher
pressure, and look at this, now we've got
ourselves a water balloon shotgun! I'm gonna push the envelope just a little and fill
this barrel all the way to the top. I counted
17 water balloons in there, and rather than
just shoot them, I'm gonna target my neighbors house! Hopefully they'll understand this is
friendly fire. But to even things up, I'd
better hit my own house as well. So there
you go! That's how to modify your Rocket Launcher
and Candy Cannon into high power water balloon
launchers. If you liked this project, perhaps
you'll like some of my others. Check them
out at www.thekingofrandom.com